COLE: Well for all of
you indies out there,
our next presenter
is going to help
you learn how to
make tons of money,
sell out, and then not be
an indie anymore, right?
Welcome to the stage
Admiral Bob Meese.
BOB MEESE: All right, sir.
Thank you, Cole,
and I'm not Admiral.
All right.
So welcome everybody.
Thanks for the joining
for the continuation
of the Google
Developer Day today.
I'm here to talk about
making money on Google Play.
So I'm the token
business guy on the day,
and this is actually
based on a presentation
that myself and colleague of
mine, Brahim, did at Google I/O
last year.
And so this is
different enough where
if you want to check that one
out to see what that was about,
you can find it on
YouTube also called
"Making Money on Google Play."
So a quick agenda
here, so just quickly
going to introduce the Play
Games BD team, talk about some
of the drivers of
the revenue growth
that we're seeing on Google
Play and mobile in general,
talking about some
developer success stories,
and so covering a variety
of different developers
from the indies to the
big guys, spending time
across the full spectrum, and
then going into a bit of a Play
update on commerce
international.
All right.
So our team, we are growing,
and so the six of us on the top
are based in the Bay Area.
We're growing quickly.
Jamil on your upper
right started yesterday.
John next to him started
last week, so we're growing.
And then all the
folks on the bottom
are our international
colleagues so covering
Japan, Korea, and London.
And so this is our team.
So we appreciate you guys.
Like we love getting
to meet all you guys.
We're still quite small for
the size of Google Play.
You'll see, some of the stats.
They're definitely
impressive, but we
want to be engaged with
more and more of you guys,
and so we're going
to keep growing.
And just kind of bear with us as
we adjust the size of our team
to suit all of you guys.
And one last shout out
to-- I had to do this,
but here's my son Isaac.
He's turning two today, so--
[APPLAUSE]
Biggest thing.
He's a gamer.
He likes racing games,
so this is Isaac.
See him on YouTube, what not.
Cool.
Thanks for that.
That was cool.
So yes.
So in terms of the drivers of
what's happening right now,
I mean, this is well reported,
but the top developers are
definitely breaking
out of the top,
and I'm not going to talk the
whole talk about these guys,
obviously because the
market is much broader,
but you've got to address these
guys because what they're doing
is really outstanding.
The breakout success
that we're seeing,
the platform level is
certainly driven in much part
by these guys.
So you look at
GungHo 2012, 2013.
This is all publicly reported.
They're a public-trader company.
You can find this elsewhere,
but it's really notable
to say more than 6x growth
year on year from GungHo.
It's really just an
astounding year that they had,
and they're driving
the overall growth
in the middle of
the games business.
They actually did
an interesting thing
as well too where
during the last quarter,
they actually broke
out that $1.6 billion,
and it looks pretty
favorable for us, actually.
Google Play is a big deal
worldwide, but especially
in Japan as well.
And so we're seeing the leading
developers like GungHo really
doing great things for us and
for the ecosystem as a whole.
Moving on to King, not that 6x
was anything to shout about,
but more than 11x
growth year on year.
These guys just recently filed
IPO and so this information
was contained there.
They didn't actually breakout
the individual platforms
in the composition there.
They did actually break
out the mobile piece,
and so they went
on the mobile side.
Mobile was 10% of
their revenue in 2012,
and last year it was 70%.
And so you can really
see just the growth
overall that's
happening in mobile,
that's driving some really big
numbers, the top of the market.
And finally, in
this set Super cell.
So for them, more than
8x growth year on year,
so you're seeing just some
really dramatic and fantastic
growth here at the top end of
the market with these leading
developers.
Supercell, as many folks
know, just came to Google Play
in about the last
six months, and so
they didn't breakout
by platform,
but they're really notable
for driving the top market.
But as I said,
there's definitely
many different categories
of successful developers,
and here you have these breakout
successes, the three companies
that we just talked
about, but the market
for mobile and for Google Play
is much, much broader than just
that.
And so there's large
developers like Gameloft
and like EA that are very, very
important developers for us.
There's a number of new
developers as well too,
and so the three developers that
I have here, Goodgame Studios,
Pixelberry, and Space Ape, none
of them were on Google Play
last year at this time.
So it is really
important for us just
to have a very healthy
ecosystem overall.
And so it's really important to
recognize the good work that's
being done by the
new developers.
And then finally
on the right here,
the small developers,
so both of these teams
are really gracious,
but the fact
remains that in
both of these cases,
two people is doing the
majority of the work
for these developers.
And so it's interesting
and exciting
to see that that still remains
a true thing within mobile
is in some cases the
mediocre, they just
launched a game a
couple of weeks ago,
and it's done quite well.
So we can talk a little
bit more about that.
And it's interesting to note too
that just the tactics change,
right?
So King, another thing they
disclosed was last year,
they spent more
than $300 million
on mobile user acquisition.
The guys on the right
are spending zero.
And so it's a really interesting
environment right now
in terms of the
different tactics
that you can take to success
on mobile and Google Play.
So cool.
So let's move on to
like a little more
about the 10 developers.
So for the first
three, I'm not going
to spend much more time there,
but the important thing to note
is around focus.
And so all three
developers in this case,
they're not getting
their revenue
from a vast number of games.
So "Puzzle & Dragons"
is driving more than 90%
of the revenue for
GungHo last year.
And so is that one hit game,
just the focus of just making
that an amazing experience is
really driving their success.
In the case of King, more than
80% of the revenue for mobile
and nearly 80% of the revenue
for the whole business
was driven by "Candy Crush
Saga" in the fourth quarter,
and so there's just a lot of
power in having that hit game.
In the case of Supercell,
they didn't break it
out in terms of the competition
between their two games,
but virtually all the revenue,
they have a third one coming.
But virtually, all their revenue
is coming from just two games.
And so that's clearly
something we're
seeing as a best practice.
There was a time when
developers are launching
a bunch, a bunch of games, but
what we're seeing right now
is the message to take from
the folks leading the top,
and their doing
some amazing things,
but focus is clearly
what's a big part of what's
winning for these guys.
In terms of the
larger developers,
one of the trends
that we're seeing
is they're adapting
to free-to-play.
They're amazing game developers,
but free-to-play is definitely
an art.
There's a lot of folks out there
that love free-to-play games.
There's other folks
there that feel
passionately the other way.
And so it's something
where you definitely
need to make sure that
you're doing it well
and you're doing it right.
And so to talk a little
bit more about Gameloft,
so they did a really
interesting experiment last year
where we worked very closely
with them for Asphalt 8.
They actually launched that
game in August of last year
as a premium game
with an app purchase.
But they had an
explicit experiment,
which was very cool, to see
how much money they could make
through in-app
purchase, and could they
make that game free-to-play.
And so there they
gave themselves
a couple of months to
develop the economy there,
and they found now the
game is free-to-play,
but the testing
that they did before
that in the month up to when
they pushed it free-to-play,
they were making nearly
3/4 of their revenue
through in-app purchase,
which was really powerful.
So it went free in
November last year.
They actually
increased their revenue
by going free-to-play because
they had built up the economy,
and then they did 24x their
installs in the 30 days
post the switch versus pre.
So it just really speaks
to revenues of piece,
but just the
engagement they benefit
from doing this is massive.
And so it was certainly
a success for them,
and it feels like
Gameloft is definitely
developing in shops
in terms of being
a great free-to-play developer.
Next big company
is Electronic Arts,
so their "Simpsons" has clearly
been the big win for them.
So in terms of just focus and
learning from those larger
developers,
"Simpsons" has clearly
been the breakout
success for EA.
It's been hanging on the top 10,
top grossing for a year plus,
and so that's just a really
impressive accomplishment.
When we think about
EA, just great brands
are just a core
part of the company.
And so we're really excited to
be working more closely with EA
to bring-- all of these
brands are there right now.
They continue to
invest in all of them.
The "Simpsons" like they're
just doing great things
with just the storytellers,
like, if you guys are playing
the game, you know what I mean,
but if you haven't, the writers
from the Simpsons are actually
writing the game as well too,
and they're having a ton of fun.
And so it's quite a fun game.
And there EA is coming
into free-to-play
where we're not going
to come up here and say,
everybody has to
go to free-to-play,
and we'll definitely
cover that later,
but if you want to compete
with GungHo and Supercell
and King, that's been
the dominate model
to get that level of
success, and so that's
what EA is shooting
for in mobile.
So the new developers, so
Goodgame, Pixelberry, and Space
Ape, just talk
about them quickly.
So as I said earlier,
none of these guys
had a game on Google
Play this time last year,
even kind of the
middle of last year,
and all have caught
our attention.
So these guys are the
guys to learn from.
For me, one of the important
goals in this [INAUDIBLE]
is just the other
developers that
are kind of noteworthy to us
or catch our attention, that's
how I want to
highlight these guys.
These are the guys who have done
variation things that we think
are notable and we want
to hold up for you guys.
And so "Empire, Four
Kingdoms" from Goodgame,
it just launched on Play
middle of last year.
It's an interesting company,
because they're a bit bigger
than Pixelberry and Space Ape.
These guys, it was
two brothers that
founded the company
several years ago,
and they were big on
online free-to-play,
but they just came
to mobile last year.
But after that
time and honestly,
we're just getting to know
these guys a little bit.
I mean, we've met with them,
but they're based in Hamburg,
and so we see them a
little less often than some
of the folks that
are based here.
But it's really a steady
rise in top grossing,
reaching the top 10, top
grossing most recently,
and so they're doing
a lot of things right.
And so just please,
there's limited time today
to go into all the
mechanics of the games,
but just for those of you who
are looking at what's working,
we think that Goodgame
is a really good example.
So a slightly different
demographic with Pixelberry
here.
I pick Truth!
I pick Dare!
I pick just making out!
So I don't know if this is
everybody's game in the place,
but they've done
some amazing things.
They just started in
the middle of 2012
and just launched on Play
just a few months ago.
But one thing that's really
interesting about them
and really differentiated
is passion about story
and not just saying
that, but if you
look at the employees
of the company,
a full half of the
people at Pixelberry
are actually writers.
And so when you
think about that,
that's just a huge
commitment to doing that,
and then you look at the
day one retention number
and clearly it's
paying off for them.
I mean 71% is massive,
and so these guys, they've
taken a very story-driven
approach to the business,
and it's working for them.
And one thing too is just
on the bottom left there,
cyberbullying is
something where,
I spoke to Oliver, the
founder and he was saying,
I wanted to know how he got into
cyberbullying because they're
doing some really cool
things with Cybersmile, which
is a cyberbullying charity.
And he said we had
started the game when
we were doing this thing and
he was reading more and more
about cyberbullying.
And he said, we have
this amazing platform
with "High School Story"
to do something about it.
And so it's actually
really cool that they
have Cybersmile-inspired
quests, and they've
had more than two million
people go through them.
And they also have a bunch
of different donations
as well as they've actually
had people who-- cyberbullying
or even suicidal situations
to be able to help.
So for here, they're
building a business,
but it's really inspiring
for us that we're
seeing them do so
much good as well.
And then Space
Ape, new developer
launched "Samurai Siege" in the
fourth quarter of last year.
Recently formed as well,
just a really talented team.
So these guys really
stand out so a bunch
of ex-Playfish and Mind
Candy folks based in London.
And so they're just really smart
and really analytical about how
they run their business, and
that's been quite fun to see.
And so that for
them, it was just
how they thought
about their first game
was just get it
out there, be fast.
They have more on the
pipeline that they're
really excited
about as well too.
But you can look at
the headline here,
and "Events" is a well-known
structure for just improving
a variety of metrics
within your game.
There's definitely a
fair amount of investment
that's required to do that, but
it can work for a lot of folks.
And so "Events" are an area
where Space Ape has really
chosen to invest and to try
to differentiate itself,
and so they have a variety
of different tournaments
that we lay out here, and you
can look at the relative impact
there.
And so the top one is what they
call a personal tournament,
or how they describe is it's
March Madness right now,
so kind of an enunciated bracket
for events within the game
where it's single player, so
not having to join an alliance,
multiround, and at
the end of that,
you have one single
winner through
that personal tournament.
In the second one we
have the "War Rush,"
so that's just a compression of
the existing "Alliance Wars,"
but rather than 12 hours, you
move it down to three hours,
and you get a lot of
good things in terms
of just the engagement in
the game during that time,
but as you can
imagine, that might
be a little tiring as well too.
So they're iterating on a bunch
of different event structures,
and as you can see
here, they're measuring,
what was the effort level
required to support that?
What did it do to our metrics
in terms of retention engagement
modernization?
And then onto the small
developer category.
So as I mentioned
earlier, some really
stand-out folks with Vector
Unit and with Mediocre,
where it's largely for
both of these companies,
about two people, which
is really quite amazing.
And the point here
is that there's
a bunch of rules where for the
large developers, if you're
looking to raise money,
build a business,
you have kind of a
different set of things,
and I think for the
large developers,
it's more important to follow
best practices where it can
be-- you're a bit
more constrained.
With these guys, if you have a
cost structure of two people,
you can kind of do
whatever you want,
and these guys are showing that.
So for Vector Unit with "Riptide
GP2," their state of premium
game and [INAUDIBLE]
is two people
have done a great job with that.
As I mentioned earlier,
so no paid advertising,
so that they do an amazing job
engaging with our community,
so they were doing a
lot of work in terms
of getting early APKs out
to developers and reviewers,
doing a bunch of social media,
doing a bunch of cross-promo
in several of their existing
games, and for them,
just taking a very sort
of throwback approach
and just not doing
pay-use acquisition.
For them too, they work
very closely with us
where they actually
were part of our keynote
last year at Google I/O
Show, where we presented some
of the multiplayer earlier,
they were basically
the reference game for that.
So I mean, these guys are
super easy to work with,
and one demonstration
of that is like,
hey, you guys mind if I'm going
to talk about you guys at GDC,
and they're like, yeah, sure.
Here's all our
revenue for the game.
And so these guys
are like super open.
You can't quite do this
with like the bigger guys,
but this is what the game did.
So this is their
Google Play revenue,
and so here you can see when you
have that premium style though,
you are going to spike
early, and even though they
do have enough
purchase in the game,
it does taper off after
that initial purchase
cycle is through.
But for them, they're driving
a quarter of their revenue
through in-app
purchases of the game.
And for them the message
here is, this is a success.
it's clearly a success
for Vector Unit.
If you're a larger company, this
is a more challenging thing,
but for smaller developers,
it's really important
that we have diversity
in the ecosystem
and you have developers
that are making
amazing games of
this quality, and you
can have a different
product out there.
There's a bunch of premium
gamers still on Google Play
even though the in-app
purchase is the dominant way
that revenue is
generated, so these guys
are a great example
of somebody who's
having success doing that.
Then more recently, some
guys at Mediocre based out
of Sweden who I've known for
the last several years, so
interesting game
with "Smash Hit."
It's blown up right now if
you guys haven't seen it.
It launched In the
last couple of weeks,
but they have an
interesting model
where it's free
with level unlocks.
So it's pretty basic
modernization in some ways,
but it's not
something where you're
going to have players pay
you over and over again.
I asked these guys
the other day,
I said, is it possible for
me to pay you more than $2
for this game?
And they said no.
And so there's a
lot of developers
that aren't willing to make that
trade-off, but these guys have.
And so some of the
changes they've
made from their previous games,
so the example of "Sprinkle."
Previously, they had separate
APKs for a free and a premium
game, but it's a bit of
an awkward experience.
And so in this case,
for "Smash Hit,"
they've actually condensed
that into a single APK.
And so it starts free and then
you have a premium unlock,
which is a really
nice way to do things.
And there in terms of the
approach that they take,
so just really
highly-polished games.
So getting folks,
it doesn't hurt
that I'm talking
about it now, but I
think they have a lot of
just folks who are just
passing the game
to their friends,
showing it to their
friends, really focusing on
that sort of word-of-mouth
is their approach to getting
the word out.
And again, too, they have other
games they can cross-promo.
They did some PR,
but again, no ads,
so it is possible
to go that route.
In terms of monetization
results, as I mentioned,
the game has-- it's a free
game with a premium unlock.
And so there, you play
through and they say,
hey, you have
these check points.
It's basically a way
to save your progress
across the various
levels of the game,
and so you play through rather
than having to start over
all the way at
the beginning, you
can save your progress at a
bunch of intermediate points.
There is really clear user value
that's created in doing that.
It's relatively simple, but
it's also very effective.
In terms of the early results,
that's kind of remarkable.
It's under two weeks.
I've just been
refreshing my phone,
but they actually hit number
one on Top Free on Google Play
yesterday.
It's pretty amazing that
two guys can do that.
And as I said, the
monetization is basic,
and I don't know if it will
exactly follow the "Riptide
GP2" curve, but these
guys will likely
spike early in terms
of the monetization
just because folks like
myself, as much as I would like
to pay them more than $2 for
the game, I can't, right?
But they have hit Top 100,
top grossing right now too,
so I mean, they are making
good money on the game.
So that was a quick recap
of a lot of the developers
that we think are doing
really exceptional things
for their businesses,
for Google Play,
and should be role
models for a lot
of the folks in the ecosystem.
So just a quick
update on our side
in terms of some of
the things we hear.
So I mean, I know all you
guys talk to each other,
but in terms of like
there are some themes
I just wanted to share with you
guys in terms of what we hear.
And so some of the developers
will come to us and say,
here's all our metrics.
Here's Google Play where I
think you guys could do better.
And so I don't know
if you guys have
a sense of what
do developers say
we need to work
on at Google Play?
Do you guys know?
So the answer is conversion.
So it's one of the things
we hear most often where
we have great
engagement, like we have
a ton of engagement
on Google Play.
Like the payers who
were done, like they're
spending a bunch of
money on the game,
but it's the conversion
piece where we would really
like to see you
guys, Google, work
on helping us convert more
of our players into payers.
And so that's something
where we hear that,
and so how do we want to do it?
Right?
So we've had [INAUDIBLE]
billing programs that
have been in place
for a number of years.
Gift cards have started
to roll out more recently,
but are really
catching momentum,
and we're expending
that more broadly.
Supporting other
forms of payment.
We're exploring a variety
of different options
and even for credit card, too.
One of things we're
focused on is just
enabling more and more
people to be payment
ready to have their credit
card on file with Google
and with Google Play.
And so how are we
planning to do this?
And of course, the answer to
this one is all of the above.
And so, we're pursuing all
of these things in parallel.
And so payments is one of
the big things for us too,
so all the great
work the developers
are doing to make
money on the platform.
A big focus for us right now,
in some ways it's not sexy,
but it's really important, where
if you have that player who
has found your game,
installed your game,
is playing your game, loves
your game, wants to pay for it
and just gets caught at that
part of the process, that
really just feels
like it's something
that shouldn't happen.
And so it's something
we're spending
a lot of time
focusing on ourselves.
And so I'll just cover a
couple of things there.
So in terms of
international, so Google Play
is strong worldwide,
but there's a variety
of markets on the left that
are some of the largest
markets for us now, on the right
some of the fastest growing.
It's just a remarkable
platform for us
as we travel more
parts of the world.
And we just see the
growth of Android
and the growth of Google Play.
It's just remarkable
and humbling.
And from a payments perspective
though, supporting payments
well in all these
places is not simple.
And so it's something
that definitely
has taken some time to work on.
So this is available online
as well too but just kind
of presenting it here,
I think is important.
The direct carrier
billing side, there's
a variety of markets like Japan
like Korea like the United
States where we have
direct carrier billing
deals with all the major
carriers in those markets.
And so those three countries are
some of our largest for sure,
and we believe that definitely
a contributing reason to that
is that the strength
of the payments options
that are available in those
markets, and we continue.
I mean, this list every
week or every couple
of weeks this list is
getting longer and longer.
This is definitely
an area where,
in some markets in particular,
where direct carrier billing is
a big focal point for consumers.
It's something we're adding.
And similarly for gift cards.
So for gift cards, there
are fewer countries
that are supported, so as I
mentioned for direct carrier
billing, there is more
than 20 countries.
For gift cards, it's
seven at the moment.
But they are some of the
most recent countries that
would have been able to--
gift cards have been Germany
in the middle part of last
year and saw a nice bump there,
and then most recently
Japan just in December,
and so we had a market as
strong as Japan with the numbers
that you saw for
"Puzzle & Dragons,"
and there, all of
2013, we had gift cards
for all of the last couple
of weeks of that year.
And so as we add more and
more forms of payment,
it enables just an
overall better ecosystem
across the way, too.
And so on the left, is the
countries on the right,
it's just a sampling of
the US, as an example
of a country where you have
the best coverage of gift cards
were based here, but a
variety of retailers there.
So you'll start seeing
that more and more.
We're supporting Google Play
branding with above-the-line TV
campaigns, and you'll see
the Google Play gift cards
in more and more retailers.
So that's about it for me.
So I just wanted to say
thank you from all of us
on the Play Games BD team,
and yeah, find me after.